good morning afternoon and evening
everyone i'm julian leo from the natural
language processing group at chiang hai
university it is my great honor to have
this chance to give the talk here
our works mainly focus on natural
language processing and knowledge graphs
and the topic of this talk is
knowledgeable pre-trained language
models
human language is closely related to
human intelligence natural language
processing has been started for about 70
years as a core of artificial
intelligence
it is a key to parsing turing tests and
realizing artificial intelligence
for human beings we require lots of
knowledge to understand complex
semantics at different levels
for example given the sentence
tom coughs today and may get infected by
covenant 19
with different knowledge we can capture
different information from the sentence
and give different responses
hence it is not easy for machines to
understand human natural language
it requires a machine to have the
ability of knowledge acquisition
representation and application
looking back at the research spectrum of
natural language processing
to some extent we are always studying
how to make machines obtain all kinds of
knowledge for language understanding
in the early stage of artificial
intelligence and natural language
processing
people tried to manually design rules
for language understanding such as
linguistic rules in grammar theory and
the knowledge basis in expert systems
this symbolic knowledge is usually human
friendly discrete and sparse
as symbolic grammar rules and knowledge
bases have critical issues of
generalization and coverage
statistical machine learning methods
have been widely applied to natural
language processing of the 1990s
the statistical measures can learn
complicated language patterns from data
the learned models contain rich
knowledge for specific natural language
processing tasks
we can actually regard the learned
patterns in machine learning models as a
form of knowledge for language
understanding
named as modern knowledge
as compared to the human friendly
symbolic knowledge
the machine friendly model knowledge
usually has better
generalization
in recent 10 years
neural networks have been introduced to
natural language processing
as compared to statistical machine
learning
deep neural models are more expressive
due to distributed representation and
deep architecture
these neural models can also be regarded
as powerful tools for building model
knowledge
in summary
the research spectrum of natural land
processing is about knowledge
acquisition representation and
application for language understanding
this is also the reason we propose the
framework of knowledgeable learning for
natural language processing
various types and forms of knowledge
have been explored in history it seems
that
modern knowledge is currently the most
effective form for language
understanding
as we have shown
we argue that knowledge is the core of
language understanding
there is a closed loop of knowledge in
natural language processing
first we learn to extract and summarize
structure knowledge from noisy text data
that is knowledge acquisition
the main challenge is how to extract
accurate knowledge from large-scale
noisy data in recent years various
efforts have been devoted to this part
second
we will represent the symbolic knowledge
in a machine friendly form that is
knowledge representation
last
this existing knowledge should be used
to guide and improve the learning
process of natural language processing
systems
this is also the focus of this talk
knowledgeable learning or pretend
language models that is how to
incorporate existing knowledge into deep
learning framework
as compared to
conventional deep learning methods that
only learn from supervised data
pre-trained language models can take
advantages of law skill and labor data
to capture rich knowledge about language
understanding
recent experimental results have shown
that protein language models can achieve
state-of-the-art performance on various
natural link processing tasks by
fine-tuning their parameters
pretend the language models can be
regarded as the most advanced approach
for building model knowledge
however
original prediction language models can
only learn from data
in fact many background knowledge is
also required for language understanding
for example the facts of bob dylan in
nulligraphs will be helpful for the
understanding of this sentence
hence give the rich symbolic knowledge
accumulated by humans it is important
for protein language models to learn
from both data and existing symbolic
knowledge
some works have been done to incorporate
symbolic knowledge into pre-trained
language models
in this talk we summarize these works
into three approaches
the first approach is knowledge
augmentation
that aims to extend model input with
external knowledge according to the
entities or concepts in the sentences
the second approach is knowledge
regularization
aims to design additional pre-training
tasks with the help of existing
knowledge to regularize the learning
objectives of protein language models
the third approach is knowledge
framework that aims to take advantages
of external knowledge to prune the
architecture of neural models
for knowledge augmentation a
representative work is early published
on ecl 2019
considering external entity knowledge
can benefit language understanding of
low resource entities
ernie is proposed to encode
both text sequences and entity sequences
as input
where entity sequences are formed by
entity embeddings in autographs
specifically the lower layer of ernie
are designed for texts and the higher
layers are designed for knowledge
integration
link prediction is also proposed as an
additional pre-training task
for knowledge integration
experiment results on any typing and
releasing traction through that
ernie can better include external
knowledge of entities for text
understanding and improve the
performance of entity reach tasks
this also verifies the effectiveness of
incorporating knowledge into protruding
language models
another representative work of knowledge
augmentation is keyboard
published on triple ei 2020
this work also aims to enhance language
representation with knowledge graphs
keyboards
at
the attribute triples of entities into
the input sequence for pretrinal
language models
as shown in the right figure
the augmented text
has a hierarchical tree structure
to better explore the complicated
structure keyboard also designs
specific attention masks for relations
between entities as shown in the left
figure
for knowledge regulation
we select kepler as an example
in this work we use entity descriptions
in autographs as a bridge between
language models and knowledge structures
and jointly learn mask language modeling
and the knowledge embedding as a unified
model
specifically we design a pre-training
task for knowledge embedding
in which entity embeddings are encoded
according to any descriptions
following the setting of structure
knowledge embedding the relation is
modeled as a translation from head
entity to tail entity
in this way we can take the structural
knowledge
in autographs to provide
additional and informative signals for
language models
experimental results show that
kepler can achieve better performance
than robota on those tasks requiring any
dimension understanding
another example of knowledge
regularization is core referred
this work explores
knowledge regularization
provided by core reference in this
course
call reference is a phenomenon that two
or more expressions in a text refer to
the same entity
for example sentence
the book refers to the little prince
called raphbert aims to learn
co-referential reasoning from last year
unlabeled corpus
specifically
it masks one or several n dimensions and
requires the model to predict the mask
that
mentions corresponding reference
after incorporating core reference
knowledge into pretrina language models
called ref birth can achieve better
performance on those related tasks such
as question answering
for knowledge framework
key adapter injects
multiple kinds of knowledge by training
adapters independently on different
pre-training tasks
different from conventional multi-task
learning for knowledge integration
key adapter
fix
the original protruding language models
for each new kind of knowledge key
adapter will initialize a new adapter
network and concatenate the outputs of
both original protruding language models
and adapters to make prediction
another example of knowledge framework
is kglm
it modifies the process of language
models with external factual knowledge
the work first conducts energy linking
and maintains a localized naughty graph
containing facts that are possibly
mentioned in the sentence
then kglm
will predict next word with mechanisms
for selecting and copying facts from
nulligraph
as shown in the right figure
the model first decides the types of
next word maybe an entity related to
existing entities
maybe a mention of a new entity
or simply a new word
if it is the first type
we will select an entity from the local
nulligraph
in this way
the learner language model can take
advantages of external model graphs in
language modeling
recently gpt3 achieves an awesome
performance by leveraging a natural
language prompt
from the tuning applies closed style
tasks to bridge the gap of input forms
in pre-training and fine-tuning
providing a promising direction to
better stimulate modern knowledge of
protruding language models
since composing natural prompts is not
easy
some recent efforts explore auto
generated prompts
or soft prompting
it is important and interesting to
incorporate task and domain knowledge
into prompt tuning
including prompt design and tuning
instances
in summary
there are in fact two forms of knowledge
for language understanding
symbolic knowledge and modern knowledge
these two kinds of knowledge can be
converted to each other
a typical machine learning framework
including pre-trained language models is
composed of four parts
input mode architecture objectives and
parameters
various approaches as mentioned in this
talk
have been explored to incorporating
knowledge into these components
okay
that's all for knowledgeable progeny
language models
with the help of knowledge acquisition
and representation
we can effectively apply the knowledge
to guide the learning process of natural
language processing systems bioknowledge
augmentation knowledge localization
knowledge framework
and knowledge transfer
the future natural language processing
systems should be able to learn
from both data and existing symbolic
knowledge
in future
there are still many open problems for
knowledge acquisition not representation
and knowledgeable learning
and the ultimate goal is to realize
knowledgeable and interpretable natural
language processing currently it is a
feasible solution
to integrate various knowledge in a
large scale protein language models and
then stimulate the modern knowledge by
prompt tuning
that's all for this talk you can visit
my homepage to find more information
about this talk thanks